[Laughter]
bill you mentioned patrice
yeah
he's one of the greats what was he like
as a person to be around
um
he was he was
he was everything everything was on tent
everything was that guy was on ten if he
was
being cool he was the coolest guy he
ever met if he was being funny he was
the funniest guy you ever met he was
being an [ __ ] he wanted to [ __ ]
kill him i still have arguments with him
like that's how like
the level of this guy he's been dead for
like [ __ ]
11 coming up in 11 years i can't believe
it but like
this [ __ ] i'm still figuring out that he
crossed the line and up because i was so
like
you know slow i wasn't up to what he was
doing
but um
you know i had all kinds of uh
you know amazing conversations just
talking about life how we ended up where
we were at how the two of us ended up
being friends
you know i'd fallen out with them i just
i had like everything i mean it's like a
[ __ ] mini series with that guy so
there's no real way to
sum him up
in a few minutes but i i will say that
you know you know if guys like
him you know mitch hedberg bernie mac
we've lost so many like amazing people
like i i often wonder like how many
tickets would i be selling if these guys
are still around
you know just one of those things
that's another way to make it live
keep living
did he influence your comedy at all did
he did he ever say to you oh man you
need to go like this way or that way or
he used to try to do that to me in the
beginning
which was funny which was classic him
because i'd actually don't stand up
longer than him and he'd been doing it
already pontificating
but like the thing about him i remember
him was like early on he was challenging
himself like going on stage and opening
with a different joke and like when
you're a new comic when you first start
like yeah you're a new joke yeah your
opening joke is your life raft yeah
that's the right thing this is going to
give me you know and he's you know he
was kind of doing stuff like that but um
yeah yeah he was you know it was we were
both two [ __ ] up
kids so we had it you know
good times bad times had to like [ __ ]
take breaks from each other i mean we
used to take breaks from white people in
general
and like i had to take breaks from going
down to the cellar sometimes it's like i
just don't want to go down there and
just [ __ ]
have to have all my deflector shields up
and be [ __ ] you know
shooting claymores over at everybody it
was a [ __ ] war it was so stupid
it's really been
glamorized that table at the cellar but
it was [ __ ]
what we did was stupid we just [ __ ]
were rip it was funny
but we never did anything creatively i
don't know
the way we helped each other was
actually coming out of that it's really
hard to hurt my feelings
like i mean i can handle it
like it takes a lot
it takes a lot uh so um
[Music]
yeah but i i you know there's so many of
those comics
you know that
you know i'm still a fan of stand-up and
i just you know
miss
besides them like
like man what would they be saying about
this you know what i mean and like um
how great would stand-up comedy be
if this like
there's like 20 of them
that were you know
better than i was that pat just seemed
to i don't know i don't know what
happened i don't know if i just got
older and i just knew people and they
were just all dying but like so many
people just passed away that were just
you know absolute beasts and they were
like on their way
to something there was a kid i i
i don't know his name because i just
discovered him um
when he passed away sometime and it just
was heartbreaking to see
this kid's stuff and he was like 28 and
the stuff he was doing in the angle that
he had i was just like oh man he
yeah he was already great but he was he
was going to be somebody that really had
uh
something to say like he he would have
been great for stand-up
um
so sucks
you